[Music]
[Music]
alone
[Music]
supreme beans will always beat you and i
seen
food when you gotta do money
i need me a good dog in the midnight
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
is
the lunatic is on the grass
[Music]
remembering games and basic
[Music]
is
[Music]
the paper holds their folding
[Music]
the paper boy brings more
[Music]
[Music]
is
i'll see you on the dark side
[Music]
[Music]
is
[Music]
you make the change
you rearrange me till i'm safe
[Music]
you lock the door
throw away the key
there's someone in my head
but it's not me
[Music]
i'll see you on the dark side
[Music]
[Music]
this
[Music]
hey
[Music]
smoothie
[Music]
young
[Music]
[Music]
and i'm sure
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
to enjoy
you can get to something and [ __ ]
have a thumbnail
[Music]
you can make real your dreams but you've
got to
know this one thing no man
does it all by himself
put your pride on the shelf and just go
down
mca i'm sure
[Music]
you can hang out with all my boys
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
ymca they can't stop you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
now
[Music]
hey
[Music]
why
[Music]
[Music]
blue
[Music]
[Music]
she was more like a movie
[Music]
she told me her name is
[Music]
always told me be careful what to do
[Music]
me
[Music]
[Music]
do a dance
[Music]
twice
be careful what you don't go around
oh
[Music]
[Music]
is
[Music]
[Music]
she just said
[Music]
cheese
[Music]
me
[Music]
[Music]
is
huh
[Music]
[Music]
is
[Music]
glasses
[Music]
[Music]
is
[Music]
[Music]
uh
come on
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
saturday
wow
[Music]
so
[Music]
every night in my dreams
i see you i feel you
that is how i know you
go
far across the distance
and spaces between us
you have come to show
you are i believe
that the heart does
[Music]
and my heart
[Music]
and never let
love was when i loved you
one true time
[Music]
let's go
[Music]
we go
[Music]
[Music]
and you'll be
[Music]
my heart will go
[Music]
is
[Music]
[Music]
my
[Music]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
you are my fire
the one desire
believe when i
say i wanted
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
tell me
[Music]
am
[Music]
it's too late
[Applause]
tell me
[Music]
now i can see that we're falling
[Music]
the one desire
you are
[Music]
i don't wanna hit you
[Music]
[Applause]
tell me
[Music]
tell me
[Music]
tell me
[Applause]
that way
ground control to major tom
[Music]
ground control to major tongue
take your protein pills and put your
helmet on
[Music]
ground control to major taut
[Music]
mission and may god's love be with you
[Music]
is
this is
oh
oh
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
spaceship
and everything
um
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
broken
[Music]
it is
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
okay
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
good job
[Music]
exactly where the hole is over there huh
is that the area just go shoot cuts if i
decide to do it
don't say nobody over here huh don't go
anywhere over here
you stay here no that's where i was
going
don't
um
alive
[Music]
uh
good uh
[Music]
[Music]
team
so
[Music]
okay
so
so
right
[Music]
two
okay
[Music]
um
[Music]
um
here
i paid my dues
time after time
i've done my sentence
but committed no crime
[Music]
and bad mistakes
i've made a few
i've had my
[Music]
[Music]
my friends
[Music]
[Music]
cause we are the champions
of the
[Music]
i've taken my
[Music]
you brought me fame and fortune and
everything that goes with it
i thank you all but it's
been no bed of roses
i consider it a challenge
ladies and gentlemen the president of
the united states
donald j trump
and i won't forget the men who died
who gave that fight to me and i gladly
stand up
next to you and remember still
cause today ain't no doubt i love this
land
god bless
[Music]
thank you what a nice group
thank you thank you very much
beautiful thank you
thank you very much please we're going
to be talking
to our great senior citizens that's what
i'm here for today
we love our senior citizens and i'm
honored to be here in
fort myers to reaffirm my solemn pledge
to america's seniors it's so important
to me i happen to be a senior
i will protect you i will defend you and
i will fight for you with every ounce
of energy and conviction that i have
[Applause]
[Music]
you devoted your life to this country
and i am devoting
my life to you
my administration is working every day
to give our amazing senior citizens the
care
support and respect that you deserve and
you understand that we've worked
together for a long time
as president i'm deeply aware that
america's 54 million
seniors have borne the heaviest burden
of the china virus
many older americans have endured months
of isolation
missing weddings births graduations
church and family
reunions you know that very well you
know it all too well
my heart breaks for every grieving
family that has lost a
precious loved one i feel their anguish
and i mourn their loss i feel their pain
i know that
the terrible pain that they have gone
through and
you lose someone and there's nothing
to describe what you have to bear
there's nothing to describe it in times
of challenge we turn to our fellow
americans for a shoulder
to lean on and we turn to god for
healing and strength
and together we will overcome we will
overcome
my message to america's seniors today is
one of
optimism confidence and hope your
sacrifice
has not been in vain the light at the
end of the tunnel is near
we are rounding the turn i say that all
the time some of the media doesn't like
hearing it
but i say it all the time we're rounding
that turn
don't listen to the cynics and angry
partisans and
professional pessimists we are americans
and we will prevail we are prevailing
and we are it's amazing what's happening
if you look at what's going on
it's been really very amazing i'm moving
heaven and earth to safeguard our
seniors from the china virus to deliver
life-saving
therapies in record time and to
distribute a safe and effective vaccine
before the end of the year
and we're really doing it even sooner
than that
you see what's going on we have the
vaccines getting ready to go
seniors will be the first in line for
the vaccine
and we will soon be ending this pandemic
hasn't happened a thing like this since
1918 1917.
that was a bad one too that was a real
bad one
i will not rest until we've eradicated
this plague from our country and our
lives and our world we want it out
when the china virus arrived we launched
the largest mobilization since world war
ii
our aggressive and early action saved
more than two million lives compared to
the
best estimates from last spring you
remember when they were giving you
estimates since the beginning our nation
seniors have been my top priority it was
obvious very early on that it was
affecting the seniors not
young people young people or they have
that strong immune system
and uh i give all credit to them but
they have a strong immune system and
99.99 think of that
but uh when you get into uh people that
have a few more years
it's a little bit it's a little bit more
difficult when you get a lot more years
it's a lot more difficult
but uh what they've done with
therapeutics now and what they've done
with all of the other things that
they're doing it's incredible
we heightened mitigation and surge
testing to protect those at highest risk
we sent billions and billions of dollars
in funding to
personal protective equipment and
distributed rapid testing to 15
400 nursing homes all over the country
we've worked with a lot of governors
you know we've worked with a lot of
governors and some have done a great job
and some have done a not a great job and
some have done a very poor job actually
but some have done a great job but we're
working very closely with
the governors of states just this week
even the new york times this was
shocking was forced to admit
that quote experts are saying with
genuine confidence
that the pandemic in the united states
will be over far
sooner than they expected and
and they're right but i was shocked to
hear it coming out of the new york times
right
i was a little sick and it's thanks to
my administration's operation
warp speed incredible people
[Music]
because of advances in treatment we
pioneered and we have been many
treatments but because of these great
advances
we've reached the point where the
fatality rate is reduced by
85 since april and now it's up to
probably
91
[Applause]
well i'm here i'll tell you
thank you
well i don't know what they gave me but
give me some more of it right now and
you can have some
no i know exactly what they did it was
actually pretty amazing i'm also working
with
the fda and hhs to make the
antibody treatment that i received it's
called regeneron plus
also it's incredible and you know what
the what they can do today is incredible
and they felt very confident even six
months ago when they started think of it
we got this all done in a very short
period of time and now we're going for
emergency use
because we're going to make it available
to everyone who needs it
for free anybody in the country
and eli lilly is making a very similar
drug
and uh alex they're working very hard on
that right
alex azar so thank you very much because
uh
i want people to get it and we're
getting it free
right so we got to do that if you need
it if you don't need it that's even
better okay that's even better but if
you need it
right you get it it's uh
really pretty amazing what happened
because i wasn't feeling great
and the next day i wake up and i'm
saying like
who can i fight today
thank you so our groundbreaking
therapies have significantly
approved and improved our outcomes for
elderly patients
but i'll not relent until all american
seniors are safe you're going to be safe
100 safe and we're right we're at a
point where really
so much progress has been made under
operation warp speed we're on track to
deliver at least
100 million doses of a vaccine this year
and uh could even be a little bit sooner
than what they were originally
anticipating with hundreds of millions
more
to quickly follow alex remember that
alex
today i'm thrilled to announce that we
have just finalized the partnership with
cvs and walgreens two places you know
pretty well i guess
to immediately deliver the vaccine
directly to nursing homes
at no cost to our seniors no cost
right no cost
and once you have that vaccine these are
very effective once you have that
vaccine you can open those doors and say
here i am
but with everything that i say and
everything i do
if you feel safer at home and you know
we can all be
like let's get out there and i felt as
president i knew there was risk but i
had to be out i can't just be locked in
a basement
to put it lock them in a basket
i felt they had to be out there would
see gold star families would say they've
been looking forward for months to
coming to the white house and many many
other people
military people and heads of state
and i know you put yourself at risk but
you can't you have to
lead your life but i say this there are
people also that would rather stay in
place stay where you are
and to those people and i understand
that very well stay just relax stay
until it's gone and it'll be gone but
stay
don't feel badly or don't feel good
about
it just stay if you feel safe stay
i'm working as hard as i can so you can
kiss and hug your children and
grandchildren very soon
that's something i missed also i will be
honest with you
as we shelter high-risk americans with
extreme
vigilance we must also allow lower-risk
americans to return to work and
return to school i mean children should
go to school
[Applause]
my young son baron had it and he had it
and all of a sudden he doesn't have it
it's like you know it was
different it's a whole different deal
and they should go to school and they
have to because
you know i talk about the cure right it
cannot be worse
than the problem itself it's a very
simple statement but the cure cannot be
worse than the problem itself
and with young children they have to go
to school they have to be with
other kids they have to grow up you
can't they can't lose a year of their
[Applause]
life and
if you look at some of you know these
lockdowns that the democrats are doing
in some states if you look at north
carolina and
pennsylvania and michigan we won the
case against her and michigan i mean
she's running
like she's running like a prison except
for her husband who's allowed to go
boating that doesn't work out somehow
fortunately they caught him he was going
to go on the lake boating oh that's nice
but nobody else was allowed to do it
but we won the case against her for
michigan
and we freed up the state and it's a
great thing i mean it's a great thing we
freed up the state
because that whole thing with drugs and
alcohol
and depression and all of the horrible
things we could go over a long list of
things but
we can't let that happen so we want the
democrat
radical left in many cases democrats we
want to open their states open up your
states and we
were very careful with our seniors and
that's different
but open up your states get it back
despite punishing
society-wide lockdowns in europe i don't
know if you've been watching
they're now experiencing a massive surge
in cases daily cases
are 2 500 percent higher in the united
kingdom as an example
and 722 percent higher in europe
than in the united states okay think of
that no think of that
and we wish them and we're working with
them closely we're making ventilators
for them for many of the countries over
there
uh we became the ventilator king i mean
we didn't have many ventilators we had
we had really we inherited
bare cupboards i said the cupboards were
bare and many of the states they had
cupboards were bare and now they're
loaded up and they're ready but we make
the hardest thing in the ventilator is
because of the complexity
of the machine and the cost the size and
but the
pure complexity and we make thousands of
ventilators now a month and we're
sending them all over the world we're
all set with event writers but we're
sending them all over the world but
hopefully you won't need them
soon you won't even need them i really
think you're gonna not need the
ventilators hopefully soon very soon
but sadly in europe the average daily
deaths are
are really soaring 402 percent higher
in the united kingdom 493
higher in europe meanwhile in the united
states
deaths have decreased by 37 percent so
let's help you right
so
the fake news doesn't want to tell you
that right they just they don't want
they want no piece of that they don't
want anything to do with that
so whether you're republican or democrat
we must choose facts over fear we have
to
science over hysteria hope over despair
and the common good over partisan
politics and
again stay if you feel good if you feel
sad because it's going to be gone
stay where you are don't leave don't say
oh gee i have to get out the president
said let's get out
stay where you i have a lot of friends
there strong people
they're senior citizens great people
very successful people hi
look she's with
thank you thank you uh but
you know there's they're tough actually
and but that you know they feel
comfortable
until this is gone and there are people
and i do that
do that i might do that if i weren't in
this position maybe i'd be doing it
myself in this position it's a little
tougher
but we cannot allow unscientific
panic-driven fear-based policies to
deny our children and grandchildren
their future and their dreams we can't
take a year or two years out of their
life
a whole social thing going on there too
these left-wing lockdowns will crush
america and my plan is very simple we're
going to crush the virus and go back to
exactly where we were we're almost
getting back there
so together we will end this pandemic
we will rebuild our economy and we will
ensure our seniors can live long happy
secure and healthy lives with your
grandchildren and your children you're
gonna hug them
right it's good under my leadership next
year will be one of the greatest years
in
the history of our country economically
we're grateful to be joined today by
secretary of health and human services
alex azar alex we're counting on you
we're counting i'm going to blame him if
this stuff doesn't happen fast right
centers for medicare and medicaid
services a fantastic woman
administrator seema verma thank you sam
a great job you billy
[Applause]
and a friend of mine who's become very
very popular i guess that was what that
big applause was i was backstage i said
who just came in
i thought elvis entered the room
it was your florida governor ron
[Applause]
desantis
[Music]
that's great ron right and by the way we
have some crowd you see what's going on
outside
the mayor said he's never seen anything
he's never seen anything like that
he's never seen anything now there's a
lot of there's a lot of love outside i
want to tell you
that's a lot of love and you know we're
leading in the state of florida just so
we understand
by perhaps a lot also with us
some warriors representatives gus
villarakis
gus just great job guys
and another friend of mine these are
really terrific people
greg stouby greg thank you very much
thank you
[Applause]
thanks as well to fort myers mayor randy
henderson
randy thank you
thank you randy good job randy that's
quite a crowd huh
that's good thank you very much and cape
coral
mayor joe coviolo joe
coviallo thank you joe great job great
job
we're also tremendously honored to be
joined by world war
ii and korean war veteran a very brave
guy
wally cortessi wally cortessi
thank you wally you look good wally
i'll tell you two wars and you're
looking you're looking good
thank you wally appreciate it beautiful
thank you very much thanks also to all
of the members of the
vfw golden gate honor guard
they're with us today thank you that's
so great huh
that's so great vfw
fantastic job thank you very much for
being here
as i fight to protect our amazing
seniors from the china virus i'm also
fighting to protect you
from another danger one which threatens
everything we cherish
value and work our entire lives to build
and to defend
as we gather today seniors are under
threat
from a radical left movement that seeks
to destroy the american way of life
we're not going to allow it
and you know one thing sleepy joe can do
nothing about it
the left has been taken over by
socialists and marxists and
extremists and they have they want to
transform our nation into a country that
would no longer
be recognizable and their agenda will
shatter america's seniors their plan to
delay the vaccine
delay therapies and prolong the pandemic
will cost thousands and thousands of
lives will
be horrifying for our country
they're planned for higher taxes they
want to quadruple taxes every company
will move out
they'll go back to where they came we
had tremendous people
tremendous companies come into our
country we're bringing tremendous jobs
160 million jobs we've never had
anything like it
before the plague and then we're
building it back up again
last four months we've set records on
employment on hiring employment
and you know a number that let's say a
year ago wouldn't have sounded great but
now sounds incredible
7.8 unemployment think of it people were
talking about 42
we're back down to 7.8 and we'll be soon
down to the number where we were
seven months ago pretty amazing
i never thought i'd be happy with 7.8
but you know when you think about it
right
it's uh they were talking 39 42
ron 7.8 is a pretty an amazing thing we
did that in a rapid fashion nobody's
ever seen anything like it actually
their plan for higher taxes and
crippling regulations however
would crater our economy their insane
energy policies
because you know they're going to be
fracking hey biden for
a year and a half is saying there will
be no fracking
then he lucks out he gets the nomination
because elizabeth warren refused to get
out
so bernie a second time happened twice
to bernie bernie
he's a hell of a loser that's one thing
i'll say
he knows how to lose well he knows how
to lose
he loses he goes back to work like
nothing happens
no they took it away from him twice i
think the second time in a way worse
because she stayed in she took the votes
and
sleepy jojo's got in there that's why
you got to be careful
you got to be careful you never know
what happens but if you take a look and
uh
we can't let any of this stuff happen
and you look at what's happened to other
countries where they've had this
philosophy where they've had this
ideology we can't let but you watch what
they're saying about the fracking
where he said no and and he said it was
such you know
it's not like well i'll think about it
he's doing the same thing with the
courts right now they're going to pack
the supreme court you see what they want
to do
would be destruction of our country but
you take a look
so he says no there will be no fracking
these are the words
there will be no fracking you don't
understand what i just said there will
be
no fracking and it gets very agitated
there will be no fracking
and he gets the nomination goes to
pennsylvania
they inform him that they have a million
jobs and fracking's a big deal
and they like inexpensive energy right
and so he goes from there will be no
fracking with great anger
to i never said they wouldn't be
fracking
it's the craziest thing if that ever
happened to me
and the media doesn't even talk about it
that's just one of many things
then he does the thing with the courts
you see that right
he goes i'll tell you left i'll tell you
after the election what i'm going to do
how important is it
because he's going to put on radical
left crazy judges that will destroy your
lives
you know it's most important they've
always said i've always heard ron i've
always heard this that the most
important thing a president does
is pick supreme court justices right
i would say maybe the military you know
but let's say it's right there
and they have to he has to create a list
of more than just that he has to create
a list
and let you know and he has to pick from
that list that's what i did i created a
list of 25 people
highly highly capable people a lot of
people said that's why i won the
election actually
so i don't know if that's true or not
but it was it was a very important
part mayor you understand mayors you
know that
so their insane energy policies will
abolish millions of jobs and cost
seniors thousands of dollars per year in
higher energy bills their anti-police
agenda will empower violent mobs and put
every community at risk their
anti-suburban agenda threatens the
property values of millions of american
seniors and your families
who own homes in residential
neighborhoods in the suburbs
i'm saving the suburbs you know people
were saying well
women in the suburbs do they like trump
i said yeah they like me you know why
they like me because i'm saving their
homes
that's why they like
[Applause]
they may not like me but they like what
i'm doing
that's more important ah
boy they have these crazy people if the
people on television
i don't know if suburban women suburban
women
want security they want safety they want
law and order
they want their homes to be protected
the socialist ideology ideology that
they will use and indoctrinate our youth
with
it's like poisonous anti-american
propaganda
the plan by washington democrats to give
amnesty and free health care to illegal
border crosses
will obliterate medicare bankrupt your
social security robbing you of the
benefits that you paid for your entire
lives
you know look take a look at venezuela
you know people don't realize that was a
wealthy country
18 17 years ago was so wealthy and it's
gone from being wealthy they don't have
medicine they don't have food they don't
have water
they don't have anything and it's uh you
know it can happen here just a much
larger version
with that ideology and that's the
ideology that they're looking at it's
crazy these radicals will destroy
medicare
with totally open borders and by the way
you know the wall
it's up to almost 400 miles
400 miles
and it goes down deep tunneling it goes
down deep and up very high i know it's
had a tremendous we've never had a
stronger southern border than we have
right now
it'll be finished very soon we're doing
10 miles a week
that's a lot 10 miles a week army corps
of engineers are also doing lake
okeechobee
and lots of other things right they're
doing a good job right
they're giving away your benefits that's
what they want to do to
anyone in the world who trespasses into
our country and you know we all have big
hearts and we want to take care of
people but when you say we're going to
give you free health care
we're going to give you college
education
i sarcastically said once we're going to
give you a
beautiful brand new rolls royce okay
if you're an illegal immigrant and cnn
went and they said
the president lied to the seniors
yeah they just don't get it they get it
actually unfortunately they get it uh
more than you would think they're a
little bit on the evil side
but you know they you're going to bring
millions of people
you're going to bring millions and
millions of people it's like
when you say free health care and free
education and free this and that
millions of people are going to pour
into the country it's not going to be
stoppable
and we can't let that happen they care
more about illegal aliens than they care
about senior citizens the democrats
the left is coming after me because i'm
defending you and that's true that's why
they come after me every day
[Applause]
but we caught him on the russian hoax we
finally caught him after two and a half
years
the russian hopes
turned out to be the exact opposite
they're the ones that were playing with
russia
that was their beauty hillary crook and
hillary
now they're the ones yeah
i i agree with you i used to just be
quiet and i agree with you 100
they paid they paid millions and
millions of dollars they paid
and they tried to show it it was the
greatest hoax and the greatest political
crime in the history of our country
that's what they
committed but i'm the only one standing
between
their open borders and extremism and the
health care benefits that you've earned
and paid for all your life you paid for
as long as i'm president no one will lay
a hand on your medicare or your social
security
as a candidate i made a sacred promise
that i'd strengthen protect and defend
your medicare benefits and that's
exactly what i've done i've done that
right
my administration has fought to deliver
greater security
affordability fairness economic
stability to our nation's seniors
under eight years of the previous
administration
premiums for medicare health plans went
up including
a 25 increase right here in florida
that's for the previous
people under my administration we've
lowered
medicare advantage premiums by a number
nobody even believes
34 nationwide
and today it's the lowest level in 14
years did you know that ron that's not a
bad thing for you to put into your
speech right
who would think that no but seriously
we've brought it way down they've done a
great
this group over here they've done a
great job thanks to our efforts there
are two thousand
thank you there are two thousand more
medicare advantage plans today than
there were
three years ago saying that's incredible
think of that
that means more choice and more
competition for better care at a much
lower cost
when we rapidly expanded telehealth for
medicare beneficiaries during the
pandemic
the number of telehealth users increased
from 14 000 a week to 1.7
million a week what's that percentage
yet all of this danger it's all in
danger because if
these other people get in they will end
all of that the telehealth
it's you know it's interesting we've
learned something for children
they're much better in a classroom than
they are on a laptop
okay children but for
your health and what you can do you can
do so much of it's such a big percentage
better than going out and going through
this telehealth has been amazing
it's been really incredible it's been an
incredible thing so it's
it's increased like six seven thousand i
think six thousand five hundred percent
and uh
it's really the only thing that came out
of this whole deal that we really
can take pleasure at telehealth so it's
been really an incredible thing that's
happened over
130 democrats in congress
including far left senator kamala harris
who's the most
left
i said he'll never choose her because
nobody treated him worse than her
nobody plus she was her poll numbers
were sinking
she never even got to iowa she never got
there
and when i said oh and by the way did
mike pence do a good job the other day
right good man did a great job
and i had a great thank you i had a
really i had a lot of fun last night
with that that was a nice
that was a nice evening it's a nice
pleasurable evening as
i have somebody going totally crazy last
night
but i told you i told you that she told
me she's going to tell
oh okay i'll believe you right no but i
i understand that worked out very well
last night that's what the word is
[Applause]
another evening in paradise i call it
they're sponsoring a socialist health
care plan
that would annihilate your medicare the
democrats policy proposals
may go by different names they put all
sorts of names they say
single-payer or so-called the public
option
but really they're all based on the same
core promise
rating medicare to fund a socialist
health care takeover and it's going to
destroy
your medicare that's the one thing you
know for sure every one of their plans
involves
rationing care restricting access
denying coverage slashing quality
extending wait times and massively
raising your taxes other than that it's
actually quite good
as we know from seeing these left-wing
policies in action around the world
seniors will be the victims and
that's what happens the first to go are
the seniors the victims are really the
seniors it's uh
you know this is nothing that unique
socialist healthcare plans always end up
denying care and coverage to the sick
and the elderly in order
to control costs and they always feel
that this is the easiest way to do it
we must not let them bring this lethal
and deadly
agenda to america don't let it happen
gotta vote them out get out and vote
democrat health care proposals would
abolish
private insurance for 180 million
americans just so you know
there are many people they've had a good
life they've done well
they have private plans they are
unbelievable they love their plan
those plans are gone those plans are
gone
it abolished the medicare advantage
program that benefits 24 million seniors
including one out of two hispanic
seniors and one out of three
african-american seniors who enrolled in
the medicare advantage right
and that would all be ended it would be
abolished
for big fat ugly socialized
medicine you go to a hospital if you
don't feel good go to a hospital room
and wait for three days to see a time
i will never allow that to happen under
my administration
your medicare advantage is safe your
benefits are protected
and i will always protect patients with
pre-existing conditions
always
always they always play that card right
you know remember they used to say oh
he's going to give up so at first they
said i was going to be in a war with
them the first week
whatever happened to that right just the
opposite
our great warriors are coming home
they're all coming home coming home
look at north korea they thought would
be a war in a war immediately with north
korea how's that worked out right
it's worked out very nicely you know
talk we'll talk keep talking
but uh it worked out very well but the
other thing that said he will destroy
your social security really
did i i said no no they're gonna destroy
because they'll destroy our country
they'll destroy your social security and
they'll destroy your country
and joe won't have any idea what
happened because he's gone let's face it
he's gone another critical issue for
senior citizens is the price of
prescription drugs this is something i'm
very proud of because
we've lowered part d prescription drug
premiums by 12
saving senior citizens 1.9 billion
dollars
but the big is yet to come i stood up to
big pharma
and that's not easy i got big money
they're the biggest lobbyists
in this country by far and i signed an
executive order implemented
a most favored nations policy for the
united states
you know for years you've heard we pay
more for drugs than any other country
well that's not even close we pay much
more
and then other countries that we know
very well take advantage of us
and they pay a fraction
i mean you wouldn't even believe how
much less
but a fraction 10 cents for a pill as
opposed to two dollars for a pill
same pill from the same lab plant
right and i instituted a favorite
nations clause
i said if germany or some other country
is getting our stuff low i want a
favored nations meaning i want it for
the same price
and they have gone crazy
i have never seen so many ads
they put on more ads against me now than
sleepy joe biden
i'm telling you and they understand
and it's uh you know look it should have
been that a long time ago
this should have been done years ago
plus i got rid of the middlemen
and i gave ron desantis the right to go
to canada in the meantime because i
think eventually you'll be
using this but in the meantime
[Applause]
you'll also be getting the rebates okay
rebates you know who they go to
the middlemen you know how rich the
middlemen are i'm rich these guys blow
everyone away i don't know
nobody even knows who the hell they are
did you ever hear does anybody know what
middlemen
would like to meet yes biden's son it's
hunter
oh
i'll bet you hunter is a middleman he's
he's collecting
he's like a vacuum cleaner he follows
his father around collecting
a lot of disgrace it's a crime family
you want to know something it's a crime
family he's following his father
hunter biden is a middleman
oh that's wild no these people are
amazing
he's middlemen you're right hunter made
no money until his father became vice
president
and now he's like a vacuum cleaner his
father goes to germany hunter's right
there
hey give me a couple of million not
couple of million hell of a lot more
than a couple of million
that's a shame i'll tell you what it's
an organized crime family as far as i'm
concerned
i capped out-of-pocket costs and the way
they get protected by big tech and by
the media the media doesn't want to ask
you know they didn't this is the hottest
subject there is right now
and i didn't watch sleepy joe less i
just wanted to see what he looked like
he wasn't looking too good
i just couldn't watch it was too painful
but
but you know they didn't i i understand
that they did not ask him a question
about this can you believe it
now think of it and stephanopoulos
interviewed me at two weeks ago and it
was
you know he was nasty he was nasty i
mean he was tough
he was he's a tough guy i watched last
night the little stuff i watched and
what i heard
it was like uh softballs everyone it was
but he didn't with this is the hottest
subject there is they didn't ask him one
question about their corruption in the
family
they didn't ask him one question about
how big tech is protecting him
big tech is not allowing anybody how
about this
they took down i guess kaylee but they
took how about kaylee
you see great no but they took that
they took down her twitter site because
she had the audacity to put up
an article written in the new york post
which is one of the biggest newspapers
in the country i think it's the oldest
newspaper in the country
and they put up a article and they took
down her site
can you believe what's going on in this
country and then they talk about
they talk about freedom of the press
they also said last night it was very
interesting they talked about the
transition the friendly transition will
you agree to the friendly trend and of
course the answer is yes first of all i
don't think there's going to be a
transition because we're going to win
but
let's let's hope we don't have to worry
about it no but think of this
they get up we demand a friendly
transition
and yet we caught them spying on my
campaign and trying to take down the
president of the united states right
that wasn't too friendly right that was
and we caught him cold
anyway let's get back to the medical
parts of the world
this is much simpler to understand if
you think about it
but i capped out of pocket costs for
insulin
at 35 a month people were going
literally they were going bankrupt over
insulin or they weren't getting the
insulin which is a terrible thing
so it's 35 a month or less for seniors
in many medicare drug plans saving them
an average of nearly
450 dollars i mean that's a tremendous
saving
many cases much less than 35 seem in
many cases much
less than the 35 right did you say one
dollar in some cases
what's your lowest number come on simon
let's hear it huh
she doesn't want to get too much i think
maybe one dollar is too much okay
she's very straight she's a straight
player and you brought it down from what
number the 35 down from what simon
tremendously yeah it's a great job but
you you did that
but uh she would come up to me for a
year and a half talking about the
insulin the insulin is the biggest
it's such a problem for people where
they just did go without if they had no
choice because it was too expensive
so great job both of you thank you very
much
i also announced that more than 35
million medicare beneficiaries will soon
receive a card in the mail with 200
that you can use to help pay for
prescription drugs
but i was going to tell you i've allowed
ron desantis now
to go to canada and buy your
prescription drugs now why
am i doing that because before all of
the favored nations and everything's
kick in which ultimately i think that's
what you're going to be using more than
anything
but canada gets their drugs for about 50
percent of what we get
for same drug same exact pill company
everything johnson johnson whatever the
company
ron is going to buy from canada
and he's just cut your price in half
right
right when are you starting that ron
when do you think you'll start when
very soon so alex get him approved up
okay whatever you have to do
i think it's great you know some people
say well that does it
my attitude is whatever the hell it
takes we have this
terrible system that's taken years and
years to rig
like the balance right like the ballots
it's taken them years and years to rig
so they're very simple go buy from
canada we get rid of the middlemen we
get rid of all of this nonsense you like
that
mayor you like that mayor both of you
it's pretty great run do it fast ron
do it fast to care for i mean you're not
going to believe what's going to be
happening with your numbers
i mean they're coming they're coming
down big we're not talking about one
percent
i mean i don't even want to mention it
but last year
out of 51 years this is the first time
the prescription drug prices
have come down in 51 years they didn't
come down much they came down like
one percent which i don't want to
mention in one way
but in another way it tells you
something first time in 51 years where
drug prices come down
but now you're talking about a 50 60 70
and 80 percent
reduction in your prescription drug
process
so we got to get it all finished uh
wouldn't it be terrible if sleepy joe
took this over the system that i've
created
and you people will say man has he been
a great president look at what he's done
like as an example transparency starts
on january 1st i said to my people you
couldn't start it like
in august back they said sir you have to
go statutorily here here here
i say yeah but i better win this damn
election because can you imagine
mayor he'll be saying boy i'm getting a
lot of credit what the hell did trump do
this is unbelievable and i promise you
they won't give the credit to us
will they huh no but uh i think we're
not gonna have to worry about it i hope
that
get out and vote vote vote
to care for our nation's veterans i
signed into law
va choice and va accountability nobody
thought that would be possible
nobody thought that would be possible
and we've also invested billions and
billions of dollars in research and
innovative treatments for alzheimer's
disease
kidney disease sickle cell disease
aids cancer and many other illnesses and
i will say this
aids will be eradicated in this country
now in six years i started right at the
beginning president obama should have
started he could have started it two
years before two and a half years before
they wasted two years
but we started it right at the beginning
of the administration
and it was a 10-year program we're down
to six years
in six years it will be essentially
eradicated in our country think of that
who would have thought that
it's an amazing it's an amazing thing
should have been started
before i got into office it could have
been
day after day i'm fighting to defend our
seniors from the virus from
big pharma oh they love me special
interests and from
the radical socialist left american
seniors remind us that
we've inherited an incredible
extraordinary
legacy you're the generation that
defeated fascism and
triumph over communism sent american
astronauts to the moon you built
a country into the greatest and most
powerful nation
the world has ever known and frankly
right now it's more powerful than it
ever was when i took over we had a
depleted military we have
now a military we have the greatest
weapons on earth
we are the envy of the world we have the
greatest weapons the
missiles rockets tanks the tankers
the freight freighters the boats the
ships
the jet fighters f-35s the f-18s f-16s
nobody has the equipment that we have in
the world not even close
even the hypersonic missiles you know
under the obama administration they saw
they stole our plans for hypersonic
that's the super duper i call them the
super duper missiles the ones that go so
fast you can't even see them
and uh now we have that you probably
read about it last night
we have the fastest by far in the world
now we're doing a great job
and our seniors and generations of
americans before you
they did not pour out their heart and
soul and blood and tears for this
country only now to surrender our
freedom our flag and our
american way of life
you as seniors have protected us and now
i as a senior and all of my people we
are protecting you
[Music]
your courage your leadership your
patriotism and your faith
are an inspiration to us all and with
your help
we will transcend every obstacle defeat
every threat
and triumph over every single challenge
we will lift our nation to new heights
of greatness and glory and america will
emerge stronger more united
more independent and more prosperous
than ever before
for our nation for our great seniors
and for our beloved children and
grandchildren
the best is yet to come thank you god
bless you and god bless america
[Music]
there's no need to
[Music]
many
[Music]
it's funny
[Music]
oh
[Music]
are you listening to me